I'm gonna ruffle a few teacher feathers when I say this
but I don't think it's that important
to teach my little kids to tell time on an analog clock yet
just hear me out there is a lot of other things that come with a concept of time
like an hour a minute morning afternoon
night am PM
those kinds of things and telling time on an analog clock
it takes a lot of additional skills
like skip counting and for my littles
they just don't have all of those skills mastered yet
so it makes telling time really difficult
but I did find this time to fly game
that has been so good in helping them practice those concepts
and learn how to tell time on an analogue clock
because it has this little airplane that helps teach them the correct time
and is a self corrector so there are these little cards that have a time
they have to be able to read it and make the time on the analog clock
and they can play independently because this checks their time for them
so if you are teaching littles to tell time
or just want to practice tell time at home or in the costume
time to fly is a great way to do that